temps alors vous allez rester avec tous
les enfants parce que maintenant on va
vous montrer va vous montrer un film
c'est l'autre coin des les enfants c'est
aussi le jury qui les ont constitué pour
juger si film que nous leur avons
présenté comme dans tout une parade qui
se respecte nous allons commencer par
celui qui a recueilli le moins de points
il s'agit de lucky luke mais nos enfants
transformé en critique quand été
indulgents puisqu'il lui ont accordé 15
et demi sur 20 alors qu'il est en
dernière place
il se pourrait bien que durant cette
semaine les jeunes réinvente le système
de notation en faisant carrément explosé
nous verrons ça à la fin de la semaine
samedi luc et luc donc il est né en 46
dans l'almanach spirou ses parents
s'appelle maurice le dessinateur et
goscinny celui qui écrit ses aventures
sont scénaristes et bien cette bande
dessinée de l'onu très populaire l élu
par les plus grands comme par les
tout-petits
si populaire comme en a tiré les films
le dernier celui dont vous allez voir
maintenant des extraits et d'alto en
cavale points de détail
monsieur luc a écouté les conseils du
comité français d'éducation pour la
santé
il a troqué son mégot contre un brin
d'herbe
à une station-service waeles kilos fu
là
demande s'il apprécie vraiment ce qu'on
fait pour eux
nom d'un chien cette petite vieille est
en danger allez on avance joly au sol
n'ayez pas peur madame
choc
la fin d'année j'ai pas besoin qu'on
l'aide
mais aidé les vieilles dames c'est la
loi du far west madame pilote cette loi
ne concerne pas du tout c'est mon humeur
est frêle pourquoi joe c'est une faute
moi j'aime bien le fait ouais mais on
n'est pas hésité mais ce n'est pas assez
bien pour la faire du gardien chef
on n'est pas assez bien pour sa prison
on repense partout en or et un cadenas
gravés à mes initiaux long on vous
m'avez suit
on a réussi on a réussi on a résisté
10 mg talent
qu'est ce que c'est bien à partir de
demain et nous rejoignons maintenant la
réalité